c'est dans cette petite ruelle de
Fontenis le fleur que Christine a
installé sa librairie il y a maintenant
2 ans elle a réaménagé cet ancien corps
de ferme et y accueille habitués et gens
de passage j'ai gardé donc les pierres
apparentes les boiseries et ça
permet un endroit convivial où les gens
peuvent venir lire ils peuvent venir
lire sur place des livres qui sont mis à
disposition qui sont sélectionnés à
travers le cercle littéraire cercle
littéraire est ouvert à tous les
passionnés de lecture et permet de
découvrir des ouvrages et d'en discuter
ensemble plus qu'une boutique un lieu de
rencontre où certains ne viennent que
pour prendre un café et discuter de leur
dernière lecture une librairie à 100
lieu des grandes surfaces et c'est ce
côté qui plaît aux clients je regarde
les livres qu'elle a les jeux
et et puis je je prends des bonbons
quand il y en a on ne se sent pas des
clients on se sans
des des voisins des gens qui font partie
de la maison des bon il y a une
convivialité un peu exceptionnelle une
convivialité qui n'empêche pas les
difficultés économiques de cette
librairie indépendante nous avons des
marches beaucoup plus faibles qui sont
définis par nos
fournisseurs des des grandes structures
comme la Fnac ou ou Amazon on des March
de 50 % en ayant les mêmes fournisseurs
que nous et nos marches se situe plus
vers les 20 à 30 % son chiffre d'affair
est donc assez faible mais selon
Christine c'est l'ensemble du secteur
qui est touché le bestseller de l'année
dernière la liste de mes envies qui est
à 16 € le prix moyen fortement diminué à
savoir que précédemment donc l'année
d'avant les livres se situaient
entre 20 22 € une baisse qui n'a
cependant pas relancé les ventes pour
Pier à ses difficult fincie vend
également des jouets et des bijoux dans
l'avenir elle envisage de partager son
local avec d'autres petites société où
chacun aura sa
plageire